I'm on this date with this guy and the
thing about a guy's guy is he's putting
his card down he's paying for everything
and I really just it sort of activated
something feral in me I'm not going to
lie we went to like another bar and he
went he was going to go to the bathroom
so I was getting prepared to pay for our
drinks cuz he's been paying all night of
course I'm going to pay for the next
round but as he's going to leave for the
bathroom he turns to me and he hands me
his credit card and he goes here's my
card get us whatever
[Music]
it might be time for me to get away from
all these you know liberal snowflakes on
the east side I love it I love this
video I love her take there's a little
touch of irony here when she uses that
phrase at the end these liberal
snowflakes but that little touch of
irony is speaking to a big truth and
she's actually feeling it and reality
remains undefeated